I mean,
what happened as far
as I can understand it,
some financial wizards figured out
that by bundling mortgages together,
you could calculate their average
riskiness and then you could discount them
according to that riskiness and then
you could sell them as high grade
investments.
And the regulatory agencies
went along with that.
And that's partly because they're
generally staffed by people who aren't as
smart as the people who were manipulating
the monetary system for obvious
reasons.
And it was brilliant.
It makes sense that if you take a bunch
of risky investments that you can and
you can calculate the risk and discounted,
then you stabilize.
It gets brilliant.
Except for one thing,
they didn't calculate the fact that
everything could collapse it once.
Now what happened was when
they transformed these risky
investments into stable
investments,
they got really valuable.
And so it was worthwhile for the banks
to give mortgages to everybody that could
possibly process.
And that's where the crookedness started.
Dis CPM,
you know,
they thought,
well,
it doesn't matter how risky be mortgage
is because we'll average that out
anyways and we're going
to make money on that.
On the trash.
I think they were called brilliant,
except for the one thing
that no one expected,
which was that the whole bloody
market could collapse at once.
So,
you know,
you can think,
well,
it's obvious in retrospect,
no,
no obvious,
you know,
like the American housing market value
peaked way below what the Japanese
housing market had peaked out.
You know,
after you decades before
it was nothing like it.
Jada,
Japanese real estate market got
inflated away past the American.
So now one,
you don't know where the talk is.
So,
and the,
you know,
the crookedness was
people's failure to play by
standard rules of risk evaluation.
But even that's complicated
because they thought,
well,
maybe these rules don't apply anymore.
And that's what the guys who were making
these bundled investments we're trying
to do.
They were trying to make the old rules
not apply anymore by eradicating the risk
didn't work.
Was it crooked?
Probably.
It's not so obvious though.